[Música]
[Aplausos]
o lápis acabaram de ouvir que eu sou
jornalista esportivo maratonista é
verdade eu me especializei nisso é já
tenho 13 maratonas nas costas umas 40
meias-maratonas dezenas de corridas de
10 quilômetros
virei uma ativista da corrida todo mundo
que eu encontro escreve livros sobre
corrida vamos correr vamos correr beleza
então o que eu vou dizer agora então nem
devesse dizer mas pela honestidade nesse
mundo das flec news eu vou ter que dizer
a verdade ocorreu um saco é um inferno
rápido demais não têm nenhuma boa razão
quando a gente começa a pensar em
começar a correr
é o nosso o nosso cérebro né ele ele foi
construído lá atrás né milhões de anos
atrás
hoje a gente não precisa correr
antigamente a gente precisava correr a
gente precisava fugir dos predadores
a gente precisava correr atrás da presa
para matar e comer e agora a gente pode
caminhando no supermercado e já está
preso em balada né
às vezes até cozida assada então a gente
não precisa mais correr mas a gente
corre
e aí eu nesse mundo jornalístico de de
perguntas eu comecei a tentar buscar a
razão para correr é e aí eu cheguei a
três causas na três grandes motivos
perder peso ganhar amigos e desafiar a
morte
então a gente vai começar pelo grande
motivo aquele que impulsiona mais gente
perder peso meu caso eu tinha nessa foto
aí 13 quilos a mais
sabia que tinha que perder e saber que
tinha que ter um pouco um pouco mais de
saúde fora a questão da vaidade da gente
da gente querer se sentir melhor
bota um tênis
é na mochila que haja você não precisa
combinar com um com um time você não
precisa estar preocupado se está
chovendo não está chovendo e dá pra
correr na esteira ou dá pra correr na
chuva também correr é muito simples e é
você pode correr e de fato em qualquer
contexto que pode correr treinando você
pode correr
conversando com gente você pode se
inscrever em provas
enfim são muitas as formas de de entrar
nesse mundo da corrida para perder peso
e funciona é a melhor relação é o
esforço caloria
se você nada você tem que nadar
quilômetros pra você perdeu um na
conseguir perder as calorias né
adquiridas antes se você é vai caminhar
sem caminhar mais quilômetros ainda
correr você é é um é uma perda muito
rápida de caloria compensa bom e aí eu
perdi os meus 13 quilos e é e aí passou
o tempo eu fui trabalhar na obra da
maior revista de corridas do mundo né
que queria fazer uma edição no brasil é
é uma revista mensal e tinha as capas e
tinha sugestões de capas que os
americanos davam pra gente e eu comecei
a perceber que as que era mais ou menos
repetitivas a aas capas na você tinha é
perda de peso perca cinco quilos né e aí
eu fiquei mas isso é chato demais isso
não funciona aí eu comecei a ver nas
vendas de revista as revistas que mais
vende um é aquelas que falavam de perda
de peso porque a gente vive uma epidemia
de obesidade né a gente até fazer
exercício na escola quando vai começar a
estudar estágio é o tempo fica menor ea
gente não tem mais tempo de defende
antes foi a primeira coisa que a gente
corta é o exercício aí a gente engorda e
aí quando a gente tá um pouco mais
estabelecido casado filhos se olha no
espelho como aconteceu comigo eu estou
gordo demais né então preciso perder
esses pesos e aí muita gente começa a
perder mais tarde né esse peso
segunda grande razão é pra ganhar amigos
é a gente vai perdendo peso vai ficando
mais né mais bonitinho né encontrar
namorados namoradas funciona essa é a
segunda razão mas a terceira razão ea
razão que me encantou
neca e aí a gente pode dividir em dois
né é esse esse item na o desafio pelo
desafio
lá e você desafiar o próprio tempo na
desafiar o próprio tempo é algo um pouco
mais complexo né
já aos 40 as células mais envelhecidas
então é é natural que o nosso desempenho
seja pior quando ele fica mais velho mas
como a gente está começando a
aperfeiçoou o treinamento a gente fica
mais rápido mais velho então é um
contrassenso né a gente está desafiando
o nosso próprio envelhecimento e o que é
desafiar o envelhecimento senão desafiar
a morte desafiar a o inexorável né isso
que vai nos pegar em algum momento eu
comecei a a a levar muito a sério esse
negócio de é de melhorar tempos
e aí corre pra cá corre pra lá aí vieram
as maratonas
a maratona é um desafio supremo não é
porque o corpo humano tem mil estudos né
ele foi mais ou menos projetado por
assim dizer pra correr uns 30
quilômetros
então até 30 quilômetros o que é um
facilmente treinando na paulatinamente
consegue correu estais 30 quilômetros
depois não
depois você vai ter que desenvolver uma
outra capacidade que é o drible no
cérebro é o cérebro dizendo meu amigo
pare na não faz mais sentido você correr
a partir de um do quilômetro 31 de uma
maratona né
o cérebro é firme lá então você tem que
educar o cérebro para conseguir chegar
os 42 quilômetros e quando se cruza a
linha de chegada da maratona maravilhoso
né pra treinar também não estaremos
aumentando e quando você começa a
treinar pra valer de verdade é você
começa a perceber o quanto você está
melhorando como se
humano né eu eu sempre fui uma pessoa
desorganizada
as maratonas me ensinaram a ser mais
organizado porque senão não dá certo se
não tiver aqui treino sistemáticos e não
organizar o meu calendário a minha
agenda do dia para guardar os três
treinos semanais os quatro treinos
semanais ou 5 seja não vai dar certo
então é eu fiquei mais focado eu senti
que é eu fiquei uma pessoa melhor
quando eu comecei não a correr maratonas
e quando comecei a treinar pra correr
pra para as maratonas não o negócio foi
funcionando até que um belo dia eu
estava nos estados unidos trabalhando
pela revista eu fui parar numa palestra
de uma mulher que eu não conhecia até
então na devido à minha suprema
ignorância né é essa mulher se chama
queda no índice swiss e ela é a primeira
mulher a correr a maratona de boston
mais do que isso é a primeira mulher a
correr uma maratona né
há até 1967 mulheres não corriam
maratonas não tinha nada no regulamento
das provas que dissesse você não pode
correr uma maratona mas eh eh eh mas
tinha um consenso que mulheres não
suportavam os 42 quilômetros ela na
universitário tinha 18 anos na época
syracuse era a universidade dela ela
percebeu que a maratona de boston que a
maratona mais antiga do mundo sair com
mais 120 anos
chegou no dia a dia muito frio botou um
moletom na e saiu correndo ela era a
única mulher entre dentre os milhares de
corredores da maratona de boston é de 67
aí o que aconteceu a organização da
prova botava jornalistas em cima do
ônibus um caminhão atrás fotógrafos né
ele estava indo já a linha de chegada
depois da largada quando passaram pelo
quilômetro 3 onde estava há aquela
incorrendo um jornalista que conhecia o
organizador da prova
jackson sampler o nome dele era um
irlandês machão 87 não o jornalista
provocou o cara diz olha tem uma mulher
correndo a prova você vai deixar né o
cara de seu do do ônibus correndo e foi
tirar aqui é também da prova na então é
pro azar do do organizador né ele se não
se deu conta né
tinha um monte de fotógrafos fazendo
essa seqüência de fotos das fotos é a
foto do meio já foi eleita uma das 100
fotos que mudaram a história do mundo né
eu vou explicar porque é é a partir
desse momento é o organizador tentou
empurrar e arrancar esse número dela o
número 261 não conseguiu porque o
namorado na jogador de futebol americano
foi lá e deu um empurrão no cara e
seguiu escoltando aqui é time até a
chegada ela acabou em 4 horas e vinte e
poucos minutos que é um tempo razoável
pra pra maratona ainda mais com a 1ª
maratona tudo certo
no dia seguinte ela chega pra chega num
café vai olhar os jornais do dia e ela
está na capa na de praticamente todos os
jornais americanos nunca uma mulher
tinha corrido a maratona uma maratona
muito menos a maratona de boston é e
começou uma discussão espera um
pouquinho né a gente está falando do
final dos anos 60 direitos civis por que
por que ela não pode correr né porque
uma mulher não pode correr uma maratona
e começou a discussão e ela é ela ia se
formar em jornalismo passou a ser atleta
né
é e pegou isso como uma bandeira uma
missão e resolveu usar isso como como um
ideal de vida né
o empoderamento das mulheres através da
corrida de rua especialmente da maratona
ela tanto briga que cinco anos depois da
organização de boston passa a permitir
mulheres correndo a maratona e hoje a
gente já tem meio a meio praticamente é
e o comitê olímpico internacional
permitiu pela primeira vez em 1986 que
mulheres pudessem disputar maratonas
parece meio banal parece idiota mas na
época é a mulheres não corre maratonas
ela foi é criou uma ong e começou a aaa
organizar provas femininas pelo mundo e
nas começou a se dedicar
quando eu descobri essa história fiquei
louco eu também quero né eu quero correr
a maratona de boston e aí eu partir para
uma busca à a ha para tentar correr a
maratona descobri que não era bem assim
não era só tentar correr
a gente precisava de um índice de
qualificação no meu caso eu tinha que
fazer uma maratona abaixo de três horas
e meia
virou uma obsessão eu passei oito anos
correndo maratona de berlim em nova york
e buenos aires sempre tentando conseguir
o índice 100 chegando perto
até que um dia nessa na capital do
estado de nova york albany eu fui e
conseguir a correr uma maratona em três
horas e vinte e seis né que pra mim é
muito rápido no meu caso eu não fui na
cia e não foi preparado para isso e aí
tem duas fotos em uma foto a prime a a
primeira foto com a linha de chegada
seria foto dos jornais se eu fosse um
atleta famoso né
a segunda foto é a foto reveladora da
alma que a minha mulher tirou é não é
felicidade e alívio eu tinha conseguido
né aí eu fui no ano seguinte para correr
a maratona e descobrir né tem um senso
de pertencimento nesse nesse grande
ambiente
e aí eu descobri quem estava na na mesma
maratona de 2017 que eu ela né a quebra
ainda estava comemorando 50 anos de
corrida
é na mesma boston né e ela aí não parece
estar com 70 anos correu nas mesmas olha
as mesmas quatro horas e 20 da primeira
corrida levou 50 mulheres com ela
correndo que pagaram 15 mil dólares pra
correr com ela na e esse dinheiro foi
todo revertido para a sopa para a ong
pra botar outras mulheres correndo e em
todas as cenas que eu via era um sorriso
imenso ela estava feliz da vida
a partir desse momento é eu comecei a
pensar
bom é eu comecei a correr para perder
peso
eu comecei a correr é depois a partir do
desafio
quem sabe eu não vou pra aquele segundo
objetivo que é é correr com os amigos
não é correr com mais gente né eu ainda
não tenho muito bem a resposta do da
razão que eu quero correr hoje mas eu
acho que eu posso deixar a pergunta pra
vocês vocês têm alguma razão para correr
a única coisa que eu posso garantir é
que vale a pena
obrigado
[Aplausos]